so i think um architecture and
entrepreneurship and product
it's it's very similar in the way you
think about
um i have a concept i have an idea of
how i'm going to make
people's life better
[Music]
all right bowser thank you so much for
joining me how are you
good how are you fantastic you know it's
9 p.m
it's after shabbat dinner where you're
at so first of all thank you for taking
the time to do this so late
and what you mentioned was that you know
this is the reality of living between
continents
right that's right yeah i'm used to it
right now definitely so architect by
profession
and then turning into a product manager
at lyft serial entrepreneur with an
acquisition behind you and now running a
startup in stealth mode
and while you can share too much about
it i'd love to hear a little bit about
the insights that led you towards this
new this new endeavor
but always take me back all the way to
to bet salem take me back to your
you know architecture days like what is
what was architecture all about because
if you're looking at your track record
today it seems so
so bizarre to be on your resume yeah i
know it's it's really not
the usual um usual way to do it
you know most of the product managers or
entrepreneurs
come from a different background but um
i wanted to be
an architect since i was i think 10 and
my best friend's grandfather was a very
good architect and and
i saw his work and i was okay this is
the profession that i want to choose
for myself when i grow up and what was
it about architecture why
so i think one thing was about creation
creativity the way that you just invent
things
and then people use them and i think
there was something holistic about
architecture it was a little bit of math
a little bit of art a little bit
of psychology and you know
he just had everything in it and it was
very appealing to me
and there was the thing about it was a
profession that
had a name it was you know what are you
i mean
it's very it's understandable you can
explain it you can understand you can
grasp
when you are a kid and when you were
wrong number two
uh something that is easily explained to
your grandmother
so uh much more difficult when you're
running a stealth startup right
exactly exactly what is it exactly that
you're doing
i'm not sure if i mean my parents know
what i'm doing but i'm not sure if they
understand
really what i'm doing how my day today
looks like
and so um i went i went ahead and
i studied architecture in bethlehem
jerusalem israel and i became an
architect
and i loved it and if you would ask me
during
my my years at bertal if i would ever
change profession i would tell you hell
no no no way
i would be an architect the best
profession in the world
i still think that i mean definitely in
terms of
uh what is architecture
the essence of it it's the most
beautiful uh profession in the whole
world
and it's a little bit different i think
the day to day
i mean dealing with contractors is not
exactly what you're thinking about when
you're
studying uh but um but but still
beautiful beautiful things to do uh and
what's
what's happened eventually was that uh i
was working
as an architect and i was teaching at
bazilla after i graduated
right uh but he had this opportunity to
come
and work for startup uh first one i was
still a student
i worked i was employee number six in
culture which
was a uh still is incredible and amazing
um and it all started back then uh we
we were working from you know i would
say in the garage the garage was very
nice
very well yeah well placed but still
um it's like it was building it's a from
from
uh from the essentials and and it was an
amazing experience and then
when i was already an architect i had
all these chances to go
and be a consultant to different
startups and i said yeah i like it i
mean i like
i like doing it so i'll do it after
hours
so i had a day job and then a night job
as a consultant one of the companies
that i worked for
was celulo which back then had a
product that was built for i think oh
almost two years and none no even one
year
user saw the product back then wow and
i mean it sounds crazy today but the
days were before
you know before the lean startup it
wasn't so obvious that you know
you have to meet the users in order to
build a good product and and
and so there was a great technology
amazing team
um and i joined a you know to start
running
the alpha the beta and and go out
and we went to a technology disrupt and
we won the first place
um i was i was started as a consultant
but
what happened was that the co asked me
to stay a little longer and
be head of
[Music]
i will marketing that for a couple of
years and then i'll go back and be an
architect
so that's of course to something
and i'm still waiting no i i'd love to
say or read
because you know the way that i'm
thinking about the architecture scene
and i'm thinking about the startup scene
you know the serve scene is all about
agile and about trying new things and
maybe back then
i know back in the day in contr culture
and saludo we still didn't have the lean
startup methodology
and it wasn't about move fast and break
things but today it's very evident that
when you're running a startup
and i'm sure that when you were running
your product at lyft which we'll talk
about very soon
it's all about trying very very quickly
things getting a lot of market
validation
when you're an architect and you're
building a when you're you know building
an office space or you're building a
building
you know you it's like the most
waterfall thing you can do right you lay
out all the plans and then you're
committing to a three-year project
when god forbid something changes i'm
just assuming so so it's interesting how
you're relating the two things but and
but you're not focusing on the
difference between them you're focusing
on on the beauty
behind each industry definitely and
i think well you said three years i
think that's true in
the in the states but in israel i think
we were not
[Music]
it's amazing i think one of the reasons
why i went and
i wanted to be an architect was this
notion of
thinking about something making it
realized and then it's going to be there
after you and that was
that was an amazing thing to think about
for me
um and and with startups it's not
exactly the same thing uh
it's not going to be there after you
it's it's as you said like
very short cycles you're building
something uh
five years from now what you build is
not no longer going to be there you have
to keep reinventing everything
um but that has a beauty of its own
in a way so i think um architecture and
entrepreneurship and product it's it's
very similar in the way you think about
um i have a concept i have an idea of
how i'm going to make
people's life better and then i'm going
into account everything that i have to
take from
all sides you know from financials and
from you know
behavioral aspects and delightfulness
and and
right all starts right think about and
then i have to translate that
to a different language that someone
else have to go
ahead and execute um so you have to do
it
so both are very very similar in in that
kind of
a way um but what's nice about building
startups is that
you see that small dance that you're
making it's not going to be there for
years it's not
you know people are not living in it but
you're making this dent and you see it
immediately um
and we just it's pretty exciting because
you see it from this
you know from scratch becoming real
uh it's kind of magic in a way um and
in larger companies uh what's amazing is
is
seeing the data is building something
and then
you're putting it out there millions of
people are using it the day
the day after and then you're starting
to see the effect of it
and the effect is amazing because if
you're doing something that
is has meaning then you automatically
when you a b test it you automatically
see the difference you see
it's it's just there that's a difference
right so you you have the privilege of
both running an early stage startup
which
which also got acquired so yours you
were seeing how you have this hypothesis
but really only to get to be able to
test this hypothesis which really is the
essence of the company
it can take a lot of time and this is
sort of the make or break moment and
then you go on and you're running a
product within lift
and you get to see but yeah so we have
this hypothesis let's just roll
something out do a b testing and within
the next day we can make some executive
decisions on
and hypothesize on how this is going to
grow talk to me a little bit about about
this
about this product you were building at
lyft and some of this process
that you went through as a product
manager perhaps even looking at some of
the lessons you learned from
uh from your architecture days sure
so actually i think in a way lyft was
um the products i built for lyft
actually i
used some of the understanding of how
cities and people work how they behave
uh yeah because um the the first product
i built for lyft was around commute
um what i was doing at lyft was running
a shared ride experience
which is basically every new experience
or or a new product
that a more than one a
um writer is using right so uh first one
was focusing on commute and was this
idea around
okay so for lyft you're tapping about a
button and you're getting a driver and
they take you to the place that you need
to go
which is um you know amazing for
a certain people or for certain
situations but
uh but if you are not making like a lot
of money right thank you
so i was trying to figure out how we can
make it
cheaper for people to ride every day
um how we can make it more
um let's say uh
how people can plan around it which was
very important
trying to figure out what's important
for people who commute is very different
for when trying to figure out what is
important when you are going out for
date or
100 by the to the to the airport
um and some of the values were around
how i can plan around it how i can know
that i'm getting exactly or a very
similar
experience every day that was very
important
the behavioral aspect was very important
more than
i imagined uh apparently people prefer
to get
let's say less superior
experience in terms of like how long
they are writing
which i think is in a way
counter-intuitive but they write rather
longer but if they're writing the same
way
they know exactly how long it's going to
take
and they're you know taking the right
from the
same spot and getting to the same spot
sometimes meeting the same people
on the way and writing with them that's
more important than
you know getting their defense um
apparently people prefer to know that
they are going to be at the office at 9
00 a.m
rather than like sometimes at 8 30 and
sometimes at 9 30.
um and so uh we designed a product
according to that that you know those
insights that we got from people
but are we how do you how do you get
those insights so is is this solely
based on analytics and you're watching
how how you know hundreds of thousands
of people are interacting with your
product and whether you're
you know what is the churn rate and what
what they're focusing on
or do you actually have to go and speak
to them personally how does it even work
so that's that's the nice thing about a
big company when you are
in a very large company with you know a
very large user base
you can do both and um
the thing about you know asking
questions
uh are you have to ask the right
questions and you don't know how to ask
the right questions and then try to
figure it out with data if you don't
have
a hypothesis so
um to get that hypothesis you have to
have good intuition
i think um and a lot of empathy
to your users and you have to speak with
them so
i would say the process in a way in the
beginning
is more like more similar than to
building a startup
and from from because you first you have
to talk
you know face-to-face with people who
experience it who uh and you have to ask
the right questions
uh you don't want to influence them you
don't want to you know to have these
like ideas
that you're having accepted in their
minds you you
have to get the real problems the real
pains
figure them out and then try to solve
them and once you do that
um you can try and ask the questions
with data
you can try and figure out uh if you are
right or wrong
and usually the right way to do it is
not go ahead and build this huge
product that is containing everything
you had in mind and have this like
amazing experience end to end all
figured out because
you're probably going to be wrong
um and then um the way i think about it
is
you have to break your assumptions to
little pieces
and try the leanest way to figure
each one out with data and once you have
that
and have you know you can start to build
your
bigger uh vision and and transform it
into a product
again something very very different from
when you're designing a building that is
meant to bring a delight to customers
and there you know you can't really just
build a
build like you know par one room and
then say hey do you like this maybe you
can i don't know maybe it's
sophisticated enough but
but it sounds like especially when
you're running a startup or product
manager at lyft
you're able to take these very small
chunks of hypotheses and implement them
in small scenarios
and test them out but but i want to talk
a little bit about the insights that are
leading now towards your next venture
which
which hopefully by the time this airs
will know a little bit about uh
what what is what are those insights
what what god you really excited into
this idea of the future of workforce
so i think one of the reasons i i was
starting to be
kind of you know obsessed with this
problem space was i was naturally taking
lifts
every day twice a day
and i was talking to the drivers
all the time uh sometimes it was part of
the work
uh most of the time just because i like
talking with people
and then i i try to figure out
what's bothering them what's you know
why are they doing it
and i felt very fortunate to work for
a ride sharing company because i felt it
gives
the drivers this opportunity to make a
living
when when sometimes they can't many of
the people
had those situations where they were you
know unemployed and
or between jobs or moving between you
know one geography to another or trial
you know waiting to get their
certificates
so um being able to buy them
you know michael i think we've got the
next week yep i think i lost it for a
second
i think we're yep yeah just so we just
repeat that again
uh so um i think that opportunity they
had
um to to be able to just you know get in
the car and start earning money
so they won't lose everything was really
important
to me it was you know a great mission a
great cause to work for
um but then underneath that
you know that big mission and and that
opportunity
lie lies a lot of problems that are
unsolved yet uh just with the right
sharing
um so talking with them i thought that
sometimes
they don't want to do it um because uh
maybe they don't have a prospect they
can't see how
they're going to have you know to
progress
or have you know to learn something new
or to have
a career path or something they do just
you know between
parts you know between jobs um
and then other problems were that they
were thinking they can
make a living but not all drivers can
make a living out of ride sharing
um it's just the nature of how those
marketplaces work is that they have you
know peak hours and
and down times and um some drivers
can you know really optimize their time
and sometimes they're very lucky and
they can get enough rights
but you're not at the right place at the
right times they just don't get rides
and they can't make a living for it you
know just
driving um well you know statistically
um more than 80 percent of the drivers
are
working on more than one platform
because of that exactly really
and okay yeah it's crazy but
that's that's uh that's the numbers
um and so i was thinking how can i make
those people's life better how can i
provide them with with everything that
is lacking um
and and how can i build a product that
will suit them
and that's uh that's how i started
overall uh
which is still in stealth mode so i'm
unfortunately going to talk a lot about
what it is exactly but um but you know
stay tuned
i love it i love it well hey you know
best of luck with overall
just in two in two sentences give me a
little bit of taste as to what keepers
was
and and you know a little bit about you
know being a first time entrepreneur
running
going you know you've joined early stage
companies before but now you're running
your own company or one of the
co-founders
you get to the acquisition what are some
of the key moments in that journey that
you're going to take with you
into your next venture
so there are several and i think and
looking at that it's
not just keepers it's i think it's kind
of a thing that was
built throughout my career and and you
can you can kind of
uh connect the dots so keepers was an
amazing experience it was you know the
first time
i'm an entrepreneur so how it was done
by you know other great enterprises at
work
done it before um and i think one of the
amazing things that i discovered that
was that i can be
jack of all trades i can do everything i
was you know right
designing the the screens because
you know illustrator skills that i i had
from
bethlehem and i was building the
experiences and i was marketing and
analyzing
the data we had and interviewing
potential
clients and i just had to do
all of it and be good you know good
enough let's say
with everything and then when i got
we got to lift i uh figured that kind of
skill
is not required anymore uh i didn't have
to do anything
like everything anymore actually i
wasn't supposed it wasn't a good idea
to do everything by myself um nick had
amazing engineers and data scientists
and great designers and they
and then i had to figure out well and
then
what is my role here um
[Music]
and i think my my main lesson was i have
to
take those like amazing people and make
sure
that the good ideas that i'm having or
resonate
resonating with them everyone knows
what direction they have to run and then
run
and they can't and and taking
that lesson with me uh actually i think
it's it's pretty much i take it
now to my new startup even though um
it's just starting and it's not casey
i still have to be jack of all trades
but building the team
uh right i have to think less
about what kind kind of team i'm
building what kind of culture
a a culture which you know
puts those people in the center of
things and
being aligned and working together and
bringing you
a type kind of people 10x engineers 10x
designers
because once you have those amazing
people you just you
have to lead the way and everything kind
of happens
the right way all right thank you again
for being so generous with your time and
for all the insights this is wonderful
before we leave i need three words that
you that you would use to describe
yourself
um okay so i would say
um a creative
or creating um that's the one thing
that's
important for me and that's you know why
i'm waking up in the morning
um the other word i would say would be
doubt um
take anything from for granted i uh
i tried to check i tried to figure out
if the assumptions are right
and i think uh that would be the second
one
uh the third one would probably be uh
family which is
the one most important thing in my life
100 and i'm sure it's going to be an
interesting ride
going through now an early stage startup
still in stealth one with the family but
best of luck and i can't wait to see
more about overall
and thank you again for being so
generous with your time it's really
great
thank you for having me take care